he still goes fishing every day just as
he has done for 20 years the Greek
fisherman Stratos Valley ahmo's casts
his nets and the Mediterranean between
the island of lesbos and the Turkish
coast same stretch of sea for more than
3,000 refugees drowned last year then
appear huge man you know there was not a
single moment during the day when you
looked at the sea and you couldn't see a
boat coming our way not one boat but 5
10 15 you cannot really imagine this
without having been here status Valley
ahmo's and his fellow fishermen were the
only ones here to help when waves of
refugees started arriving on Greek
shores in 2015 and all they had whether
tiny fishing vessels good became the
direction of the most dangerous thing is
that the people who are not familiar
with the sea even when the waters were
calm people drowned and I couldn't
understand why but then I saw it with my
own eyes if you cannot swim you just go
down like a rock the schemata esta
rolita do you properly like the
fishermen thousands of Islanders
volunteer during the crisis half a
million refugees landed unless was alone
the pictures went around the world
showing a vacation destination
transformed into an island of misery the
large numbers of refugees passing
through have taken their toll on the
island of lesbos locals here are worried
about their Islands image only this
summer hotel bookings went down over
sixty percent and while arrivals the
refugees have fallen sharply many remain
stranded on the island now scattered
around lesbos more than five thousand
refugees are living in places like this
commit Stavros Magoo yiannis has been
running this camp but since the start of
the crisis after the eu-turkey refugee
deal went into force his camp became a
dead end naww negation of infusion apush
voyeur foto de Gama
gang who has the right to turn our
island into a warehouse for human beings
we as locals and lesbos we don't like
this at all of course we need to check
who's eligible for asylum but no one has
the right to keep all these people
stranded here Chandra Bose Englishman
ocean and topo Stratus Valley ahmo's
village was one of the epicenters of the
crisis
the 40 year old also works as a chef in
one of the three small restaurants here
this summer the tables remained empty
and the small community is worried about
the future for status right now the
Nobel Peace Prize nomination is of
secondary importance we don't need to
get a prize to know that we did the
right thing biggest prize for me is that
there are human beings somewhere who
remember that I saved them that is
enough for me miftah America left is on
the refugee crisis has transformed the
island of lesbos and the life of
fishermen Stratis Valley ammos if the
boat should start coming again status
says he will go out again every day and
this time he will be even better
prepared